♪ ♪ ♪
- Fait que ça, c'est toutes
mes gratuités...
- Geneviève Primeau s'adonne
au couponnage depuis une dizaine
d'années.
- Pour 2021, ça valait 10 81
ce qu'on a acheté, 1029 $
que j'ai payé de nos poches
et les points accumulés;
1863,50 $ en points PC.
- Avec le temps, elle a
développé plusieurs astuces.
- J'envoie des lettres de
compliments aux co
Je demande des coupons, puis
c'est toujours des gratuités
pour faire connaître leurs
produits. Des fois il y'en a
un, deux, trois, quatre dans
l'enveloppe.
- Elle accumule aussi,
évidemment, des coupons-rabais
plus standards.
- Sur des sites in
des fois dans le Publisac, sur
les produits beaucoup, puis dans
les épiceries évidemment, il y a
de coupons d'afficher.
- Elle utilise ces coupons
seulement lorsque le produit
est offert en rabais en magasin
maximise les points
des programmes de fidélité.
- Moi je ne vais jamais
à la pharmacie si c'est pas
un 20 fois les points.
Donc c'est 30 % de remise
sur ma carte à p
- Elle constate, par contre,
que les promotions sont moins
nombreuses ces temps-ci.
- C'est plus diffi
je trouve, cette année parce
que justement les produits
sont tellement plus chers.
T'sais, des fois il y a un p
moins de coupons.
- Ce n'est pas qu'une
impression, selon Sylvain
Charlebois.
SYLVAIN CHARLEBOIS, dir. labo.
analytique agro., Uni. Dalhousie
- Vraiment de façon générale
les rabais en magasin,les circu,
il y en a de moins en moins
depuis le début de la pandémie.
C'est la survie, c'est de
travailler avec la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
déficiente.
- Déjà, les coupons sont en
général moins généreux au Canada
et il n'est pas possible de
les cumuairement
aux États-Unis. Mais avec
l'inflation, les détaillants
devront probablement être
un peu plus généreux.
sais pas ssais pas ssais pas ssr
plus de couponnage, mais moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on va faire
un effort supplémentaire, que
ce soit de par un programmeté pu
plus de coupons ou autre chose.
- Et les consommateurs ne
devraient pas être gênés
d'utiliser des coupons enqu'ilss
ou électroniques.
STÉPHANE LACASSE, dir., aff.
pub., Asso. détaillants, QC
- Ils sont toujours
les bienveux dire,veux dire,veu,
pour nous, c'est un moyen
de faire connaître des
différents produits.
On sait aussi avec le coût de
a certains
ménages qui ont peut-être
des difficultés à acheter
certains produits alimentaires.
- J'ai des beaux coupons de 4 $
x-là. Le Cachemire
va être complètement gratuit.
- Geneviève et Martin utilisent
environ 20 % de ce qu'ils
achètent. Ils donnent
à des proches et à
des organismes communautaires.
MARTIN RAINVILLE
- C'est ce qu'on a accumulé,
je dirais, au cours deux
derniers mois, deu
mois et demi. Donc on est pas
mal prêts pour aller faire
un don dans pas très long.
- C'est une forme de bénévolat
dans le fond, parce que j'aurais
peut-être pas nécessairement
le temps d'aller faire du
bénévolat quelque part en dehors
de mes heures de travail, mais
là ça, ça se fait de la maison.
Fait que
au suivant.
- Le couple consacre environ
une quinzaine d'heures
par semaine au couponnage.
- Je pense qu'on n